the jurogan experience you know that
knee you landed on frankie was
crazy i was by myself watching tv and i
screamed out loud
you know it was one of those oh yeah and
that's a common thing in my house are
you okay
i'm like watching the fights yeah that
was a nasty one dude was so perfect
yeah it was you timed it so perfect
yeah i mean he wasn't doing any of the
hit and the breaks
you know everything he was doing was
just forward forward forward he threw
you know he threw a kick forward
he threw a combination forward and i was
like oh this guy's
not hitting the brakes at all you know
uh and i was like
you know just throw something into that
space that he was going to step into and
you know he could have been more perfect
yeah
yeah he was like right before he threw a
punch everything
yeah so two wicked kos in a row like
that over two
top guys like you must be feeling right
now that you're on like a whole new
level
yeah i'm trying not to feel too good you
know because that demon
you know that demon will tell you hey
you're good enough man you know you're
good enough ride it out yeah um
yeah i do feel good though man i feel
like uh i think it's been noticeable
the demeanor that i go into the cage
with it's it's noticeable in my brain
too like when i'm walking into the cage
uh i'm ready you know to hurt someone uh
and i'm ready to uh i'm ready to you
know snap
and get the get that 10 weeks of
thinking about it out of me
uh but yeah man i i i'm super happy with
it man
i feel like you know uh it's it's it's
own ability
to figure out where you best perform and
like you you you don't learn that
unless you have you know a loss or
or you get lucky and you get you get to
win a fight but you know i had to lose
and
um that's how you learn that stuff and
i i really feel man like when i'm in the
back in that space
i feel 100 percent completely
untouchable
you know and that's something that is
very very different than when i was
fighting
before like i'm walking into the cage
now feeling
100 untouchable and you attribute this
to the work with the mental coach as
well as just you realizing that you were
flat in the algae main fight
yep yep and just realizing where i do
best you know just realizing where i do
best like uh
i would love to because i'm a calm dude
like i'm
a relaxed guy like i don't get too high
or too low about anything like it'd be
nice if that
if i could perform at that level you
know but that's not the case for me so
i need to really and that's why i do it
before sparring is i'll make sure
no matter how tired i am regardless of
what's going on you know if i'm injured
if i'm
you know over trained whatever it is
when it's sparring day i'm making sure
that i get myself to that same place
um obviously not intense enough to where
i'm gonna hurt my training partners but
i'm making sure that i can replicate
that headspace regardless of
the situation yeah you said something
after the fight when you were talking to
you were talking to laura senko so you
were talking to uh no it was uh
andrew uh whoever it was
yep that person um you were you said
some people go in there and they're
looking to compete they like to compete
and that's what they're doing you you go
there you're trying to hurt people
that's that's you know what i'm doing
now
you know uh it was really uncomfortable
for me because like we're kind of you
know i like hinduism i like eastern
philosophy i like the idea of like you
know
buddhism and you know being really
peaceful and having a zen mind and
uh and not wanting anything and and
being really free from all the suffering
of the world and trying to get there
uh and that was kind of my philosophy
you know up until i was choked out by
sterling and
opened up my eyes and i hear him running
around and celebrating
and i was like [ __ ] that you know
[ __ ] that everyone that i go into a
fight now with i'm really trying to hurt
you know like i want to be the guy
that's running around the cage and
they're opening up their eyes you know
and
and i didn't you know uh it's it's a
it's a different type of space to be in
and it takes a lot of
practice especially for someone like me
who isn't you know naturally like that
uh but you know that's
that's the game that we're in and that's
what i'm trying to do now
how important is a law sometimes super
important
it's it's a reminder you know and like
you said you know i was just too
comfortable
i was too laid back like i needed to
remember how dangerous this sport is
uh and that's one of the main things
that i took from that loss is that like
we're not playing soccer like don't walk
into that fight
not ready to go it's also a lesson right
it's like
failure is so good for you
because when you fail it sucks and it
feels terrible but
if you needed motivation well there it
is like
that's the best form of motivation like
people would love to get motivation
in a totally positive uh
like a way where it's elective like i've
decided
to be motivated yeah i'm going to be
positive and that's wonderful
but my goodness the injection that you
get from a loss
or from just straight up failure where
you're like oh my god i'm a
loser yeah yeah the feeling it's so
bad you're literally the same person you
were
before that moment but now you [ __ ]
hate yourself you hate everything you
feel
terrible you can't sleep you get up to
take a piss and you can't stop thinking
about it like
[ __ ] you just feel safe you nailed it
but
that feeling is worth a [ __ ] billion
dollars it's so
valuable i wish i wish i could
win fights and feel like i lost every
single time
i wish i had that like that type of
superpower i wish i could do that
do you think you could talk yourself
into that feeling is it like the feeling
that you got after the algemean fight
can you think you can like bring
yourself
back to that state yeah yeah
um yeah if i sit and think about it long
enough which i sometimes
you know like and not not because of
that fight but just
all of the shitty things like you said
that happen after a lost man like all
the shitty conversations you have to
have with people oh my god like the
shitty looks you get what do you think
went wrong
yeah hey man uh you'll get it next time
it's like no man like this is my
existence bro
you'll get it next time yeah yeah
non-competitors that want to talk to you
about your losses i hate it look on the
bright side
yeah you got your health yeah in that
moment
there's no bright side and that's
something that every athlete i think has
to come to grips with
the during losses there's there's no
upside
it's just this is your look sometimes
you're the hammer sometimes you're the
nail
and you don't get the good without the
bad the reason why the good is so
[ __ ] amazing is because you felt the
bad
yeah if you're just this guy just
stormed your way to the top with no
adversity whatsoever
you probably wouldn't enjoy it as much
no and and that uh
that emotional pain i think is worse
than physical pain
and i remember after the first time i
lost i had like my own existential
crisis a little bit where i had to you
know
venture off and really question like who
i was as a person where i where i was
putting a lot of my identity just
because that [ __ ] hurts so bad man
and uh i remember like if i keep doing
this
it might happen again you know and i had
to i had to like sit with that a little
bit and i was like
and you might not even get what you want
out of this and then i was like damn and
then i had to sit with that
and then i was like and then i but i'm
really grateful for that because that
was the real moment in my life where i
was like
martial arts is is my path you know like
that's what i'm doing
that's what i'm doing i remember having
the very lucid thought of like
when i was having those feelings of like
uh this could happen again
you might not ever get into the ufc you
could be doing this and win some lose
some and be a loser until you're
35 40. you know and in my head i was
like
okay you know i'll sleep in a box i'll
be a loser
you know as long as i get to do this
with my life like i'll be that loser
and and kind of since then that's when i
was like oh i actually love this
you know catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience